Although Sony and Marvel Studios have shared
custody of Tom Holland's Spider-Man so that
he can exist in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
alongside the Avengers, the former studio
is still pushing ahead with its own universe
of Spidey villains and anti-heroes.
"Venom" was a surprise hit back in 2018, raking
in $856 million — so audiences are clearly
interested in Sony's edgy approach to superheroes.
It's no surprise, then, that the studio is
working on a solo "Kraven the Hunter" film
starring Aaron Taylor-Johnson, as well as
a "Madame Web" adventure with Dakota Johnson
and Sydney Sweeney.
Meanwhile, Jared Leto's "Morbius" is finally
set to arrive in theaters on April 1, and
it's been a long time coming.
The movie was originally intended to debut
on July 10, 2020, but that was delayed almost
immediately— and then the pandemic hit,
causing Sony to push the release back several
more times.
"Morbius" follows Leto as Dr. Michael Morbius,
a genius who is determined to find a cure
for the rare blood disorder that he's suffered
from since childhood.
His research leads him to an experimental
procedure using bats, and it transforms him
into a vicious beast with the comic-accurate
gray skin and red eyes, enhanced senses, super-strength,
and the ability to fly.
Unfortunately, he also has to contend with
Matt Smith's Loxias Crown and FBI Agent Simon
Stroud, played by Tyrese Gibson.
The first reactions from critics have made
their way online, and they paint an interesting
picture of Sony's latest Marvel movie.
Collider contributor Sab Astley blasted the
movie for its poor story, tweeting,
"Morbius is about as bad as you were expecting.
A 2005 plot collides with visually confusing
CGI to create a bit of a snooze fest.
But don't worry, they've saved the worst for
last.
Featuring some of the worst post credits scenes
you've EVER seen, Sony are off their rocker."
The We Have a Hulk podcast's Nicola Austin
echoed the sentiment, noting that it doesn't
live up to the "Venom" corner of Sony's Marvel
universe.
She posted,
"Well Morbius is unfortunately not great (some
really shoddy vfx & 00s formulaic plot) & definitely
not as fun as Venom.
Really confused at the future of the Sony
Spiderverse following the post-credits scenes
& the editing."
Meanwhile, Escape Film Club tweeted that the
film's visuals can't save it, posting,
"Morbius proves that no matter how many famous
faces or shiny visuals you squeeze in, Sony
will always find a way to impressively misunderstand
basic storytelling."
Film critic Ren Viera followed that up, writing,
"Matt Smith gloriously hams up the place and
Oliver Wood delivers some visual flare to
the action sequences.
Aside from that, the bad plotting & messy
cgi, confusing editing & worse sound mix result
in absolute incoherence.
But the post-credits manage to outdo it all."
One of the biggest questions fans have about
"Morbius" is: When is he going to meet the
other Sony Marvel characters, like Venom?
Obviously, an earlier trailer reveals a look
at Michael Keaton's Vulture, which implies
that a Sinister-Six style team-up is on the
way at some point.
Sony has been keen to make a movie about the
squad of "Spider-Man" villains for quite some
time, and the original plan was to spin it
out of "The Amazing Spider-Man" franchise.
For the moment, it's not clear if, or when,
Morbius will cross over with the likes of
Venom, Vulture, or Kraven.
Although, Jared Leto previously told Screen
Rant that of all the Marvel characters the
Living Vampire could meet, quote, "Venom would
make a lot of sense.
That would be fun."
It's worth pointing out that just because
the film has had a negative reaction from
critics doesn't mean it won't be successful
at the box office.
At the end of the day, if "Morbius" is hugely
profitable, then Sony will likely continue
to use the character in sequels and crossovers.
Leto himself revealed on "The Late Late Show
with James Corden" that he could easily cross
over into the upcoming "Blade" movie.
For now, it's probably best to go into "Morbius"
with a little caution.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.